first of all let's get started what's
going on in the chess world what's the
most important thing going on yes it's
Norway chess welcome
it's Norway chess 2015 yes that's
excellent
besides that actually in st. Louis
something pretty cool happened this
weekend the was a chess camp in the st.
Louis chess club but it wasn't a chess
camp for beginners actually the chess
camp was taught by Garry Kasparov and it
was attended by only five students by
invitations grandmasters cadent Rove
sam-7 and Jeffrey Zhang International
Master
Akshat Chandra and I think international
masters soon to be or something I wonder
Leon with an average age of about 13 I
think and an average rating of about
USCF 2650 maybe so pretty strong
tournament camp sorry and I was
interested on some of the things that
they were doing and actually had the
opportunity to sit in one of the classes
just to look and one of the many things
that they had to do well they had a
training session so a puzzle solving
session if you will where they were
giving a lot of and games that were even
though they were compositions they had a
lot of practical value kind of being
able to use ideas that are well-known
and applying them to make your
calculation really quickly so we're
gonna take a look at one of the
positions that they looked at this is
actually the fifth puzzle in a series
the series was like this they had ten
puzzles and one hour to complete them so
whatever it is they wanted to analyze
they could analyze in whatever order
they wanted but they were expected to
solve most puzzles in the range of four
to six minutes and they went on
increasing difficulty so this is kind of
medium difficulty if you
so we have this position it's been up on
the screen for a while so I'm sure that
you guys have at least looked at it a
little bit tell me can somebody tell me
what's going on in this position it's a
pawn endgame very good now it looks good
this gets down with the characteristics
of pawn any games before we get some
answers porn and games are unique
because there's no such thing as the
evaluation slightly better slightly
worse looks good looks bad no the thing
about pawning is is they can be
calculated towards the end so there's
only three evaluations why it's winning
blacks winning or draw well we have to
figure out is what the position is yeah
we have a lot of interesting ideas in
this position creating a passport is
absolutely essential in King and ponen
games so we have to analyze sometimes
the obvious and if the obvious is to
create a passport and we have to analyze
now in this position we have what's
called a calculation tree and basically
we should look at what possibilities we
realistically have in this position so
what do you guys think is possible here
right
Julian h6 is definitely worth looking at
in order to create a passport on the F
file who else has an idea it's not not
not a trick question
right we are we got to start for the
audience right just because it's a
composition doesn't mean you gotta go
look for the wacky moves with always
white in compositions always always
right sorry for I forgot to mention that
but white in compositions is always so
when you're giving a puzzle to solve
it's usually always always white so in
this case yeah King f2 is something that
we have to consider now we're gonna move
the pieces around because I'm going to
keep and I'm gonna let you guys cheat
but remember that the students that were
at this camp we're not allowed to move
anything so they just have to calculate
in their heads so King f2 is definitely
what we have to look at first now what
would be what scares me the most here
from black yes
right we got the we got a look at this
king commenting and taking all my pawns
and we also have to look at d4 which
would the d4 would simply win the make
up past poem there so definitely King h7
is what I have to look at first
d4 fails I believe to just pawn takes
before but I think c4 is also quite
accurate in this position and it just
allows me to get the pawn with an extra
tempo since I've been able to push my
pawn one position further remember that
when we swapped all the Kings side pawns
for the Queen side pawns my position
would be one tempo ahead because now the
points on c3 rather than on c4 so that
would be important in with some
variations that we're gonna look at but
let's start with King H summon the king
h7 which one king h7 no we're gonna have
to see it we do not think we calculate
so we're gonna figure it out King h7 and
white plays why is this a horrible what
would you play this which pawn right but
actually the purpose of this cheap own
as we will see soon it's not of a
defensive resource it's an offensive
phone as well so what would you play
here and you would play King to g8 right
but I mean that's white how would you
punish me for making this horrible move
give me 3 sounds good I'm gonna play
King h6
so here we go into somewhat forcing line
king d4 I take my take
ah I take ng3 King c7 King takes f3 King
takes G 5 c4 g4 here here here here here
here here
draw agreed yes everybody agree with
this variation wrong you fell for the
first trap of the puzzle this position
is actually lost for white after King
takes p7 yes
Keeney for the imaginary game in the end
is a draw indeed of course but hereafter
king e4 actually black wins notice that
you cannot play c4 because I simply
capture the pawn and you're outside of
the square so for example after c4 king
d4 you lose this pawn right importantly
after king c6 trying to get my King back
into the game if I play King takes King
d6 King before King e6 King efore I lose
right I have to play king f7 and then g5
that's completely winning for black so
after king e4 black wins so suddenly we
see that in the initial position even
though nobody had any clue if I was
playing for a win or a draw it's clear
that's actually very dangerous for white
if the obvious alternative was just
racing is lost for white something needs
to be done and this is clearly very
dangerous for the white side but what to
do this seems pretty forcing king f2
King h7 King III King h6 this all looked
force right so we only have one more
move to look at yes I'm okay so after h6
we have basically two moves to see right
the first is what happens if I take
yes
do you have to King g7 King III King g6
now if you go to d4 I go King h5 the
steak steak in g3 and this one we don't
we still need to count but after King
here h3 takes here I do not Queen on
time because interestingly and we have
to go back to a little bit of theory
about pawn versus Queen and games when
you have a lone Queen against the
seventh ranked C pawn is that a draw or
a win when the point is already in the
seventh rank right Queen again spawn
just queen against pawn but the point is
on the C file the King's too far away is
that unusually a winner I draw usually a
draw right
the reason it's a draw is that I can use
stalemate tricks to but but exactly
there's a pot on f3 in this position so
after Queen B one check and the usual
maneuver up the board it doesn't really
matter how we get there eventually we
get to this position and here usually
the trick is that you go King a8
threatening to promote but you can't
because here I just can't take the pond
and laughs you still have an F pawn to
move so this is losing in that case we
actually need to come up with a new idea
instead of this in this position
important is the move f4
first of all if King H 5f5 actually even
wins for white right there's no way to
stop the F pawn since the King has caged
himself out of controlling the key
squares if instead of that they go king
f5 suddenly I can go king before takes
takes and the extra tempo that I just
want allows me to Queen at the very same
time that you queen you check sorry you
don't Queen others thing how you check
your queen with check but there is no F
point there is no F pawn whatsoever so
after King ba this is a draw an easy
draw of course because of the trick on
sale made on a eight so the entire point
of F 4 was to disappear your f your F
pawn you allow your opponent to Queen
with check and it does not matter so in
this position we have to see only one
more move right this is pretty
straightforward takes here here here F
for sorry F 4 is already drawn this
position is a draw you can calculate it
out a little bit more but this is a draw
so instead of that we're gonna have to
this position after h6 do we have any
other variations g6 right but this seems
to be the same stuff if I go King f2
King h7 King III I mean I'm still losing
that endgame right so what's the
difference
sorry ah yeah we played a move h6 and
then g6 right for for black so does this
make any difference
anything at all
actually the idea is very subtle the
point is that we're going to go into the
exact same variation that we just saw
mmm duck pond never queen with Chuck in
the other variation here we had the move
Keaney for winning because exactly
because after see for King D for King
see six takes King D six here here here
this pond was forced to move one square
therefore it's not protecting the F six
position and now after King F six this
is a drop so again the line straight
forward from this position is King F two
King H seven King III King H six King D
four takes takes takes takes King G
three King C seven takes takes chief and
after G five this is a draw but instead
the correct move is king e for and after
C 4 which is White's best attempt King D
14 C six trying to bring the King back
into the game
King takes e4 King D six we have all of
these moves that are similar but in this
case white loses because you don't have
the move King f6 if I start the entire
variation with h6 I forced to move G 6
then we go into the exact same thing but
the pawn is now lost because of King F 6
and white achieves a draw so what do you
guys think kind of like a little nifty
detail there with h6 that was very deep
in calculation now I have to remind you
that when Kasparov was showing showing
this puzzle there were no hints there
were no ideas you were simply told why
to play find the best move and there are
26 ft and that's why there 2650 I'm not
entirely sure how many of them was able
to solve it because there was of course
on a series of Hart puzzles but I
thought it was really interesting the
ideas that they're forced to calculate
in such a quick
Manor and the fact that they're able to
use so many ideas that should be known
to them in order to solve the puzzle
quickly for example when they get into
the sea pawn against the Queen they
don't have to calculate it out they know
that's a draw but they also know that
it's losing with the pawn on f3 all
these little details that they had to
analyze in order to come up with a good
evaluation all right so you guys
actually this is a very difficult puzzle
of course it's very hard to understand
we're gonna see how some of the best
players in the world actually mess up
their own positions so we're gonna take
a look at some of the games played in
Norway some good end game since some bad
we're gonna start with three really bad
ones so that hopefully will make us feel
better this is the game between Hikaru
Nakamura and Fabiano Caruana from Norway
the super tournament that's being played
the first leg of the grand chest tour
the next one will be coming here to st.
Louis August 21st where all these guys
will be playing and this game was played
a few games a few days ago and it is one
of the most inexplicable games that I've
seen in my entire life so it shows that
even at the top level bad things happen
to good players after the move King C 3
we have a relatively even endgame it
seems like Nakamura might have a little
bit of pressure because he has the
possibility of sometimes pushing the
pawn to d4 and if I'm able to force you
to take my pawn on d4 and I could
recapture with a pawn I still only
create a passed pawn and you have a lot
of difficulties making this structure
into something useful that being said
the game is very close to a draw even if
somehow you managed to achieve that and
it's not entirely sure clear that you do
because when you do play moves like d4 I
can just ignore it I don't have to
actually take your point right so a lot
of problems here and yep karana with
still some minutes on the clock
panicked it is completely unclear what
he saw or what he didn't see but he must
have seen some kind of ghost because he
spooked himself into playing a bad idea
first he played b5 which well let's see
who can tell me why b5 looks ugly
Julian
right it's just like you isolated your
pawns for no apparent reason here like
your c5 pawn is now weak you're a five
point is now weak but okay this is not
the end of the world the king should be
able to protect them it's still not them
whatever b3 was played by Hikaru looks
like pretty decent move and then caranas
masterpiece of the event the move g5 one
of the worst definitely one of the top
three worst moves on the board I think
just behind giving up the rope it's very
it's very weird to see players of this
caliber making this kind of mistakes but
it proves to us that it happens it
happens to all of us and well if it
happens to Khurana maybe it'll happen to
you but just don't play this badly okay
so after after g5 what we have a
position where I just could not believe
my eyes when I saw the move g5 because
Nakamura simply took the pawn took the
pawn and now he gains the strategic
advantage by simply putting the rook on
h1 the rook isn't an open file gifted to
him by Khurana he didn't even have to
open the file himself and now he has an
excellent idea of going rook h5
harassing the pawns and it's going to be
very difficult for black to keep them
alive after the move rook a7 rook h7
there has to be some credit given to
nakamura of excellent technique in this
endgame this area might already be
winning but he showed very convincingly
how to do so so after rook h7 Corona
played the move f4 trying to destabilize
the situation on the Kings side the idea
is that if you capture twice sometimes
after the move a4 takes rook takes I can
even let go of this pawn on f7 and it's
not gonna be so easy for you to just
force your F pawn remaining in some
positions as this point is still
actually quite weak so if rook takes f7
the move for okay - I'm not going to say
this is necessarily a draw but it looks
pretty draw
I mean you only have one good point to
push and it's not entirely clear that
you can just win with it alone
instead of that much better technique is
to play the movie for ignoring the pawn
for now and letting it sit weak on f4
saying that I'm gonna bring my rook into
the game later and round up the phone
while I preserve a strong pawn structure
since the plan of rook age for rook
takes f4 is so strong
knock Khurana decided to play a four
trying to create some counter play
before his pieces just collapsed
so pawn takes a for-real takes a four
rule takes f7 was played
now could he Carla cameras up a pawn but
it's not over yet check here check now
the king must retreat all the way to e1
in order to keep the defense of the
important F pawn well that's okay
King e1 rotate three King it to okay to
check King f3 and an excellent fine here
by takara was that after rocked it to
rock d7 king c6 root d5 black was in a
weird kind of zugzwang
there's nothing that he can actually
move obviously if he plays the pawn on
c4 then I am c5 to c4 I simply take it
if he goes away with the rook this way I
can what was I doing with I can play the
move d4 after which the trade of pawns
will allow me to eventually Romania
where the Brooke again capture this pawn
and be up two points if he moves the
rook to d1 he loses control over f2
allows me to take on f4 immediately
winning the game and if he plays the
King which is what he did he not can
work and play the move e5 advancing his
pawn even further so a nice little idea
here from Hikaru after rook d5 black was
completely lost
king c6 and it's funny that he used the
exact same idea again he played route
the 8th King c7 rook d6 and again black
is in zubur
if you move the King I push the pawn if
you download the King we already saw
what happened so a nice little maneuver
there even though he also had the nice
idea of playing ecigs in this position
letting his rook hang since after king
takes d5 eise evan there is no stopping
the pawn on the seventh rank despite
despite check on d3 you just take the
pawn or play anything else really and
pawn is unstoppable no sorry sorry
you're right King g4 is in G first but
disregard kingi for is much better and
now the point is actually unstoppable so
kind of a blunder thereby karana but he
wasn't the only one making blunders in
this tournament so the leader the leader
currently in Norway is a dude called
Veselin Topalov and he's actually
leading with an amazing six out of seven
now the first round game he beat Magnus
Carlsen
although beating is not exactly the
correct word Magnus Carlsen forfeited on
time in a winning position as he just
kind of forgot how time controls worked
at the grand Chester
he thought that I'd moved 60 he was
going to have an extra 15 minutes and no
such thing existed so he simply let his
flag fall expecting 15 minutes to come
and they didn't and the arbiter stopped
the clock and Apollo won the
psychological impact that that has had
in the tournament is obvious the pile of
took that victory ran away with there
now leads with six out of seven while
Carlsen is in ninth place out of 10 only
ahead of this guy John Ludwig hammer who
also gave the Polish a pretty nice gift
in the following game this is already
the fifth round and the follow has a
commanding position in the tournament
four and a half out of five playing
black Eakins judge mu big hammer and a
very crazy game was played and it's
actually a very interesting game to go
to and go look at there was a piece
sacrifice that he sacrifice backfired
then the Polish had any initiative
she made a mistake hammer had an
initiative he made a mistake then we got
a weird end game hammer seems like he
salvaged the game love to go through it
but this is an end game lesson we're
gonna focus on end games and in this
position it seems like hammer finally
did it he finally found a way to draw
the game good for him
so after rook takes f7 check which was
done with excellent calculation King
takes f7 was played and we have a
dangerous situation here for what it's
obvious that he's down material but more
importantly this King is very quickly
coming to f5 taking my pawns and it
seems like most pawn and games are
easily lost for example this this this
this I push my pot on 87 the Bishop
sacrifices for my pawn and then
obviously I lose both of these and
there's no one to stop the Jeep on right
simple calculation this shouldn't take
too long so instead of that the point of
the position is that you go King c4
gaining an important tempo so after the
move Bishop a7 you go King d5 now you
have a strong threat you're trying to
play sorry actually my back there is no
particularly strong thread in this
position black sands of zone if you go
King g7 I play King e6 and I force my
pawn to f5 on the next move exchanging
blacks last pawn and extinguishing his
hopes of winning the position meanwhile
if Bishop b8 I have the clever idea of
going king c6 white threatens to win
with the move King b7 as the bishop
would be kicked out of the defense of
the a7 square once that happens I push
my phone and get a new queen way before
blacks able to do anything therefore the
only good move in this position would be
Bishop a7 and then instead of going
after the bishop which is suicidal
I repeat moves by putting my King back
on d5
a little bit of a clever continuation
there so we again return to this
position the Pala pretty much resigned
to a draw play the muki 7 whatever and
in a completely inexplicable
mind circuit loss of brain power
something happened
hammer for God that his idea in this
position was to play the move f5 and
after takes 18 e5 the pawn is now lost
that is the last pawn that black has
with an easy draw notice that this is
actually not a threat in this position
because after f5 takes King if I have to
move king g6 defending the pawn but the
King has to move it either allows me to
go to e6 or it lets me play this
variation with Bishop e8 King c6
therefore this position of central team
e7 was played a hammer played king c6
when I saw this position on the board I
I mean I lost it I was in the commentary
here downstairs at the club and I just
didn't understand what happened maurice
was shocked gen didn't know what to say
we were like what was it a transmission
error did this guy forget how to play
chess and you could see it in his
expression like king c6 to fall of place
46 why not right you just bring the King
in and then we know that all the
opponent games are lost and hammer just
sat back in his chair rocked around for
a couple of minutes looking at what he
had done to his position signed the
score sheets threw it over the board and
the pile of looked over some variations
with him but he was obviously disgusted
and how can you not be when you get
invited finally to an elite event like
this you he actually earned his
qualification by winning a strong
tournament with fresene a and some other
top Scandinavian players and he's
finally here he's playing Vesely to
follow up with the white pieces yes an
interesting game it should end and
probably one of the more interesting
games of the round with that draw I
think it would have been like probably
not necessarily a game of the day but
very close to like rocket spotlights on
the guys to the last game remaining of
the round and then he does this I don't
know what it is about this tournament
some kind of curse for the Norwegian
players but they're currently said
on ninth and 10th place and I don't
think the Norway is particularly happy
with the situation a recent headline
from VG one of the main newspapers in
Norway read with it was translated to
something along the lines of Carlson
looses again horribly this is
embarrassing
this was a fifth game of the tournament
between John Ludwig hammer and Topalov
by this point Carlson had already lost
three the fact that hammer didn't
improve the situation so nobody was
particularly happy even John Lurie
camera has had some interesting chances
discernment I said not being able to do
anything with it and he's actually the
subject of the next game his game again
and why did I put this in here does this
have any interest in now okay so we
might we might look at it if I run if I
run up examples so we actually got this
really cool end game between hammer and
mashaallah graph and this was one of the
trickier things and I think a hammer
thought he was winning and he wasn't
happens so we got this opposite color
Bishop endgame in which the rooks are
still active and blacks up a pawn of
course the fact that blacks proponent
something nobody cares about when
there's a massive pawn on d7 right
almost ready to Queen now unfortunately
for hammer because of the opposite color
Bishop existence blacks able to set up a
blockade on the dark squares however
things are not as obvious as that
there's a lot of problems because once
Armour puts in the move rook e1 you are
threatening the lethal rook e8 cutting
off the rook from defense of the pawn
what
let's turn have sex let's play relax so
yes so Bishop f6 was played in order to
keep control over the d8 square so after
rook e8 things don't look great because
it looks like this King might be able to
maneuver itself around to the c7 square
and push the pawn forward now there's a
lot of work to be done before that but
let's take a look at what happened
maxime first played a very important
move the move h4 is necessary not
necessarily here in this position but it
must be done if you don't play h4 you
run out of counter play and we're gonna
your attack like what counter playing
well the point is that you're creating a
passed pawn in this position gen low big
hammer decides that this pawn is
worthless and it's pretty close to
worthless because it's only the other
pawn that matters right the passport he
decides I can let this guy go it doesn't
matter from now
g4 this pawn cannot move forward or it
will be captured and this pawn cannot
move forward or it will be captured so
even though black has to pass pawns
they're not as dangerous as the single
pass form from white and therefore now
controlled so here it's not so clear
what maximum can do with the black
pieces he started to shuffle King g7f
for King Bishop da King g2 Bishop f6
Bishop d3 Bishop d8 you have 3 now again
if the pawn on the H file moves I simply
play King g3 I capture that pawn and
then I go back to where I need to be
Bishop f6 Bishop f1 hammer Rimini versus
position in order to control both pawns
at the same time Bishop d8 now that I
can go he plays King in for Bishop f6
King D 5 black can no longer shuffle
with the bishop back and forth because
he needs to keep defense of the pawn on
d4 but that's ok he still had to rook to
shuffle around he can play route GA drew
cafe king c6 Bishop da and it would seem
that White has a decisive resource
in this position to take the bishop play
King c7 force the pawn forward and then
win the bishop against pawn endgame the
pawns are already controlled all I would
have to do is bring the King back and
take them basically right and yet that's
not quite true
yes so in this position
gentlemen big hammer play group takes d8
after the game you could see in his
expression that he thought he was with
you and he was actually quite
disappointed with himself but the truth
is that he doesn't have a win it seems
like blacks barrier here cannot be and
the fortress cannot penetrate it there's
no way around if you don't sacrifice
your rook here you're never going to be
able to do it if you play King b7 I can
still shuffle if you move the King
outside of the 6th rank I'll go back
with the bishop basically never allowing
you to play the King to c7 so this is as
good a chance as it gets king c7 rook f8
are you say after Queen and now the
excellent move by the worthless pawn
they move h5 the position without the
foreign h6 is actually lost actually
every move in this position that's not
h5 looses the game but an impressive
resource from holograph and I think this
variations even though there's a bishop
here reminded me a little bit of that
composition we saw at the beginning
where you have to sacrifice one of your
H pawns to disturb your opponent's pawn
structure and in this case it's very
similar actually it's even possible to
lose this position if you play g5
any ideas on how to win
very good h3 Bishop takes h3 the three
now this pawn is passed I'm trying to I
cannot play Bishop g4 to stop it so I
have to go back Bishop e2 even though
King g6 might still win I think it's a
little unnecessary right the pawns
promote by themselves because the bishop
will eventually be overworked it cannot
stop the d2 pawn and the h2 pawn at the
same time with a winning position so GT
xh5 is forced King h6 King e7 King takes
h5 and now Bishop e2 check notice that
at this position the King cannot come
forward anymore if for example King f6
King g4 give me five a very important
move here King f3 now again blacks going
to threaten to play tf2 making the
bishop choose between the pawns if he
doesn't do that he takes here then I
take on f4 and that's the last remaining
corn for white and at that draw instead
Bishop e2 check was played king h6
Bishop f1 again because the bishop has
to control both of the pawns bishop f1
is again forced King takes f7 losses in
a similar manner but we can just count
the Tempe and black is faster than white
the pushing the f1 is not as fast as
pushing both bonds
so instead Bishop f1 King h5 f5 was
tried as the last-ditch attempt but
after king g4 f6 we had to move h3 on
the board if hammer takes on f 7h - now
you have to stop this pawn d3 King G
seven D seven F 732 f7 d 1 f1 both sides
Queen at the same time with a dead draw
this would be a draw easily even without
the existence of the H pawn the bishop
and queen
cannot overpower a queen not by a long
shot it's actually quite an easy draw
it's that it's more difficult when it's
Queen at night
but even that's also a drop Queen and I
versus Queen without any pawns as a draw
so instead of that after Bishop takes h3
King takes h3 King takes f73
we had a pretty obviously draw an
endgame and hammer had to accept the
Queen trade with a strange but very
calculating very sharp and interesting
draw
fortunately hammer has been close to
winning a couple of games he was much
better at miss viola graf and he was
actually much better against Apollo at
some point but he hasn't won any games
happens when your opponent's find
resources like this right it's difficult
to win games I wanted to show another
game from that tournament and it's
actually the game between Aronian and
Khurana and we're gonna go over it very
briefly because I only have 9 minutes to
show it and quite honestly this is a
position that if you put it in Kasparov
scamp they could probably spend the
entire day looking at this they could
probably just bang out variations for
the entire day and never come to a
conclusion on the endgame evaluation
luckily for me I can cheat and I can
just ask the computer what's going on
and it's usually it's right but not
always Queen it depends on the strength
of your laptop or computer that you use
so here we have this interesting
situation between Aronian and Khurana
and Khurana has to make move 40 in this
both sorry 39 in this position and he
has two choices
he can play Queen g6 which preserves
about equality or he can win upon with
the trick Queen takes 3:3 check yes I
wanna point so unfortunately for him
this losses after King takes to 394
check King f4 9 t xf64 unfortunately for
Khurana his King is not this King is
going to num-num all those pawns on the
Queen side and there's nothing he can do
about it so this game falls into
superior for white and it's very
difficult for black to play but he still
has some chance
after the moves kingi 694 king g 5 king
t6 Khurana went for his only idea in
this position to play 94 take on e3 and
try to push this pawn before white
pushes his so Knight c2 was played in
order to simply defend the pawn King f5
King takes d5 no reason not to take this
pawn before going for the Queen side if
I don't do that after king c6 there's a
lot of chances that here this one will
be a crook
that's not how phones move this pawn
will be a liability later in the game so
let's go ahead and take this guy and I
have six checking c6 not King e4 takes
and King D 3 and this is where we have
one of the most interesting positions of
the tournament and one of the most
difficult situations to evaluate it's
clear that white is up a pawn but it's
also clear that black has a lot of
counter play the King on d3 is powerful
the pawn on e3 is falling the pawn on f7
will eventually be passed so even though
White's pushing for a win this is very
difficult to calculate so I wouldn't be
surprised
Kasparov shows this game at some same
some other lecture although to be fair
these kids are pretty well informed so
it's very likely that they've already
seen the game and seen the analysis but
here actually there's only one move that
wins for white it seems like it's taking
out of a composition like nah that's not
real life but actually the only move
that wins here is the move Knight b4
check everything else draws the idea is
that in the variation after King takes
III King takes a5 this Knights actually
better posted than it was in the game
since it restricts this Knight a lot
more than it does and the variations
that we're going to see with the move
that Aronian chose and if the knight is
taken as it looks obvious then after the
excellent move King c6 it becomes clear
that this King cannot catch this pawn
and that this Knight doesn't have a good
way of rima new virile
into stopping the apon nights are
particularly bad at stopping a phones
because they run out of squares to do it
from so you can count as much as you
want but this thing game is lost there
is no way for black to hold on the pong
will force promotion there is no way to
sacrifice the night for it
it's simply lost but it looks risky
right I mean there's a lot of to
calculate still first ignite does have
some remaining ideas like 98 97 94 95 it
could be helped by the king the king
could try to take this one and Queen his
own pawn and just everything fails by
about a temple it doesn't matter which
variation you go to blacks always a
temple laid there it's a difficult
decision to take on a practical game
right but it was the only winning plot
plot 91 check was played which seems a
lot more human and fortunately for
Aronian after King III King a5 there's
an amazing draw in this position though
I believe that this one is much more
logical than the sacrifice of the knight
here the correct move is Knight d5 and
the reason the 95 draws and here as I
said I don't have time nor the
willingness to show every single
variation that spawns from this position
but logically the knight does belong on
d5 since it takes away both b6 + b4 from
the king and if Kings b5 s ever played
and this pawn gets all the way to the a6
square I'm gonna have to move Knight c7
check in order to sacrifice my knight
for the remaining pawn therefore you
have to make sure that for example after
f5 here here here I don't have this
resource of attacking your knight
playing King c3 and eliminating your
last point you would have to be careful
that this doesn't actually happen
unfortunately here for white there's
just no way of making progress after 95
this should be a draw even though it's
still very complicated to calculate all
the variations out it still seems like
there's a lot of tricks for white but
they fall short just slightly short and
this is one of those positions you can
analyze for a long time not come to a
conclusion easily the computers seem to
think that this is a draw and are
usually right in these positions I think
this is already a table based one two
three four five six seven yeah
there's already a table based position
so the computers know for sure that this
is a win or a draw and they say draw so
I believe them candy to was played
instead which looks very natural it
attacks the night and allows the King to
come into the fray by playing king c3
and trying to stop the pawns
unfortunately it falls short not if
three check King c3b 495 b5 and notice
that in this particular scenario the
nine is not as well placed to sacrifice
itself in certain variations and because
I kicked out the night from f3 we're
gonna from the passive position on e1
and went to f3 we're gonna see how this
night actually helps white win the game
after King b3 it looks like blacks why
it's not able to make progress if I play
b6 then after Knight takes p6 can takes
b6 I eliminate your last pawn but now
running to play the move Knight e5 first
of all this attacks the power on f7
right so if you lose the power of seven
you're toast so he has to play f5 but
after the move Knight d7 I help promote
my pawn with the night so that after the
move for example f4 b6 Knight takes
Knight table no computer this one f3 I
easily stop the pawn with the night I
put my knight on f1 and this King cannot
stop this one right that should be
somewhat obvious maybe yes
right so this position is already lost
Khurana decided instead to play them of
93 because you know I don't know why but
after b6 night c4 chucking b5 check in
see 694 King C 595 king b5 finally
Aronian got rid of this night since
after Knight b7 the move Knight c5 check
needs to have pretty obviously one pawn
endgame so a nice little resource there
from
our minion player us after the move 95
he is actually indeed winning since the
night is helping him pushed upon forward
it wasn't his only win but it was by far
the cleanest so 95 a very important
resource a nice little end game that had
so many like nooks and crannies there's
so many difficult ideas in this position
of course the counter play is probably
blacks best bet but the fact that it all
comes down that the end game it all
comes down to the fact that it's winning
because of the move night before is it's
quite surprising the way these things
work you have to still be very precise
in certain occasions and luckily for
Aronian Khurana didn't find the drop
after the move Knight
II won check which he made in the game
as we saw Knight d5 was the correct move
and the only drawing chance but he
missed it and Aronian was one able to
win what was a very complicated endgame
but still full of practical value
because well guess what this does appear
in real chess games so it's important to
know some of the common ideas and the
fact the night before is playable should
at least enter your mind in the fact
that it's very common that a king is
able to dominate a knight in order to
not let it attack an a pond or H pawn
and here obviously the king is
completely caught out of play alright
those were some end games from Norway
2015 I hope you guys enjoyed it